we're joined by CBS news radio military
analyst Mike Lyons Mike good morning
morning from what we know so far how
effective was this operation I taste so
far so good not only did we get the
chemical facilities but I think going
after some of their air defense
capability is gonna be the underlying
success factor of this I you know
initially the previous administration
was afraid that any kind of airstrikes
would come up against a very robust air
defense platform but last night proved
that we kind of got through now the
propaganda has already started the
Russians claiming they shot down a lot
of missiles right but I do think from
the military planners perspective
knowing full well that they got through
those air defense systems is gonna give
them a lot of confidence should they
have to do this again how can you be
certain and ascertain exactly what was
taken down on those chemical weapons
zones
you really can't the information we have
comes from the ground likely from
Israeli intelligence forces we don't
have a lot of human assets that that are
there but we'll do what we can satellite
imagery as well there's still other
targets there we could go after this is
wasn't just a few that are left that he
still has some capability that I think
we're gonna have to be looking over the
horizon to make sure we take out next
time
as you mentioned Mike I mean the
Russians are saying they intercepted
some of these missiles and they're also
pushing back hard as is Iran saying
there will be consequences for this what
should we expect well we've got to be
worried about the 2,000 soldiers we have
inside of Syria we've got to protect
them make sure that they're not going to
come under any kind of fire I think
we've got to be a little more creative
than just you know a standard
conventional force possibly electronic
warfare possibly some kind of cyber
operation that the Russians could do
they could become more disruptive to our
naval forces into the Mediterranean
there's other things that they can do i
but I think deep down they don't want to
get into this confrontation with the
United States conventionally they know
that they'll lose but we'll find out as
to us or not whether or not this attack
crossed any kind of red line like you
mentioned those two thousand US troops
there in Syria the president said that
he wants to phase them out remove them
from the area where do you see that
headed now in light of these strikes you
know I thought the president's instinct
was correct initially when he said that
about taking those troops out a lot of
people were surprised we had them there
they're there under the same
authorization of use of military force
that put troops in Afghanistan after
9/11 so I do think Congress
to revisit this 2,000 troops can't hold
the ground that they're on there there's
no their training Kurt forces they're
nowhere near this fight in Damascus but
I do think that that this strike will
force this administration and the
Congress to rethink our strategy not
only by Syria but Russia and Iran as
well that there are major players in the
region and we've got to be concerned
about what we're doing both inside of
Syria and then over the horizon Mike
Lyons thank you for joining us Michael
it's probably